today we got a bell pepper sandwich let
me show you how i made mine
janelle is it busting or what
yo mom's how's the food
kourtney kardashian and her daughter
penelope disick just got in
on tick-tock's busting trend no not the
busset challenge
the is it bustin janelle trend and well
it's bussin thank you just in case you
aren't familiar with the viral trend
let me get you up to speed it all
started when janelle rohner
a popular tick tock creator known for
sharing her keto
low-carb lifestyle shared a clip
weighing in
on the bus it challenge the one where
people transform from comfy
cozy loungewear to full-out glam i've
seen all the comments and
and duets and i have to be honest i have
no idea what busting means
like i have no idea someone please fill
me in cause i'm so confused
yeah so she admitted she didn't know
what busan means
and that kicked off a new viral trend
where fans edit one of her videos eating
food
to a video where they ask the influencer
if the food is
bustin enter court's eight-year-old
daughter penelope
who crushed it yesterday we got a bell
pepper sandwich let me show you how i
made mine
janelle is it busting or what
yesterday we got a bell pepper sandwich
let me show you how i made mine
janelle is it busting or what
and earlier this week the proud mom of
three also hopped on tick-tock to share
this clip with a friend at nobu in
malibu
yo moms how's the food
it appears her 11-year-old son mason was
behind
the video because she captioned the clip
quote whatever mason says
i think keep it fresh keep people
interested
in case you're still trying to figure
out what bussin means it's slang for
really good and janelle she finally gets
it
snack time in my car and i got a bell
pepper
half a cucumber and a cheddar cheese
stick and to answer your question
yeah it's busted